[Music]  we've been talking backstage and you've  been talking about how you're obviously  so beautiful in you're in great shape  and I was talking you said that you do a  lot of yoga I do and and you actually  said that you do that you were gonna  show me a yoga move out here and I will  not be denied I beg you  she didn't want to do it but I said I  just I want to see you do this yoga move  and I have to take off my shoes if I'm  going to be really doing this and I need  your help okay Oh  [Applause]  [Applause]  okay settle down fellas so I'm gonna  need you to step for what do I do  stay straight this is called the  Scorpion okay  and because usually you do this in a in  a yoga studio and there's a wall so I'm  gonna have to use you as my wall okay  boo hoo okay such an idiot I'm sorry  [Applause]  [Applause]  best job in the world